[Music]
we all love playing games the fun the
tension the natural high of a win it's a
lot like the buzz we get when we look
for a mate especially now the
gamification of dating through apps has
got us hooked at least oh you with oh
yeah he's from Marseille Oh missed and
we're obsessed downloading more and
spending more Cupid's arrow has been
replaced by an algorithm it's like it's
like in tinder when you swipe and it
says that you get the match it's like or
do you want to keep playing like it does
turn it into the game
Zuri Rachel and Lily are typical
twenty-something single young women
looking for love
I was actually match with a porn store
and I didn't even realize it was a porn
star we didn't end up going on a date
because he started asking about my
sexual preferences and I thought while
he's told me about his lifestyle you
know I will be honest about my and I
said what my boundaries on her and he
actually said I don't think it's gonna
work out your boundaries are far below
what you should be tinder is it's like
something a mom told you never to do
like never be a strange man on the
Internet and then we're just they're
like well maybe I should do it but like
many seem nice some of them are like
some of they're not nice a revolution
that began with tinder just six years
ago
has transformed the way the sexes meet
there's been an extraordinary cultural
shift the old stigma has gone and now
the expectancy is if you're single
you've just got to be on one of these
dating apps and that explains why we
spend so much money on them more than we
do
other entertainment like Phil's music
the UK spend on the top 10 dating apps
reached its highest in the third quarter
of 2018 increasing by 60% rising sharply
from fourteen point four million pounds
in the third quarter of 2017 to twenty
three point 1 million pounds for the
same period this year excluding games
tinder generated more consumers spend in
the UK than any other app in 2018 even
more than Netflix and Spotify and the
UK's increase in spending on dating apps
is higher than the global average the
old protocols an elaborate dating
rituals of our forefathers and mothers
have gone all the fun of the fair has
been replaced with the dopamine rush of
a tinder match it's a numbers game
low-risk high-yield you're not going to
stray away we can find a guy like within
five minutes like you couldn't even be
chatting with someone for five minutes
and then half an hour later you could
actually be you know in my house for me
it's a lot easier yeah then actually
going interpreters you can set I can sit
here and get up my phone and find a
hundred or people and it's easier to
just go for them like a card log and
just be like hi hi hi hi hi not actually
going to meet them updating promises a
world of erotic social mobility where
you can hook up with anyone regardless
of class or status but is this true the
potential matches you're offered are
selected by a computer program is it
just an echo chamber but the technology
does have the ability to skew our love
lives sometimes in completely random
ways
Christopher is out-and-proud
a confident gay man until one day he
left his dating app open and one day my
teller was just opened two girls
accidentally and I was just kind of
going for it and was just and it just
took it as it is and just like hey how
are you
people messaging back I was just know
nothing that he really thought about or
I've got a delve in the rest or I'm
gonna completely change this it was just
like okay well why not and the apps are
helping you to do that it's not
something you would oh yeah in real life
yeah 107 the technology is impacting all
of us as individuals like Christopher or
whole strands of society young and old
for example teens are having less sex
than ever before according to one report
that's because they're too busy having
online relationships which never move to
the physical level and st is in the over
40's is increasing that's because the
divorce rates are rising but these
people are having more dates and more
sex because it's never been easier there
is no subject that has been talked about
or written about more love and romance
relationships and sex it's what defines
us but with every swipe we're learning
something else about our developing
dating habits in a study of a hundred
and fifty thousand uses of the site ee
harmony researchers at the Oxford
internet Institute discovered 95 percent
of users send requests to at most 12
people a week and they reply to less
than 7 messages now this suggests that
online daters have a maximum number of
people that they communicate with at any
one time so we're learning more about
our online dating behavior but we're
still not sure what effect all of this
and dating is having
on our mental health because updating is
a bit like online shopping we're
presenting two diversions of ourselves
for others to make snap judgments we've
become utterly disposable commodities
there are people on there that aren't
very nice the lowest is when you find
out the person you're dating is still on
the app I think that's the lowest
because that makes you feel awful like
you're not good enough then there's the
ghosting suddenly disappearing without
trace and no explanation I've had a few
ghosts and I can kind of like almost
sick sense it I think so I had one
recently went on a really good I went on
two really good dates the end of the
second day I left and I was just like
he's just never gonna contact me again
but did you know I just it just felt
like that I don't know I can't even
really explain it
I'd love it if there was an app like
TripAdvisor but for men or women that
you've dated and I've done something
awful and you can advise other people
star rating yeah exactly
there's bad behavior and then there's
the disgusting racism that's flourished
online like the kind suffered by Ashton
on Grindr it would find their BIOS and
quite like ignorant statements they
would say like oh no blacks know this
they'll be like no this no that no this
no that and whereas a black person
you'll see in like that and so many
different profiles like no blacks it can
kind of fit you because you think like
do people not find black people
attractive I mean what I mean what's
wrong with me I mean I've even got like
on here some screenshots from stuff
that's actually happened here's one
supposed to call me the n-word and then
he brought me straight off the map WTF
many app companies are trying to address
bad behavior and this startup in
Manchester the team thinks data's want
to change
looking at your talk and seeing that we
cover every users face with a jigsaw
puzzle you might think we're a bit mad
we only cover their face we know it's
the most important part but it's that
piece is covered to incentivize that
conversation but what is so important
definitely in the early stages of dating
apps there was that you know is instant
access in the palm of your hand I can
get people you know people's profiles
who I've seen my could meet up with as
quickly as possible just thrown at me
and go from there based on a photo but
people have become more mindful as time
has gone on everybody's a little bit
more self-aware about how they're using
social media and online you know
platforms and and we see ourselves as
coming up to the time where people are
looking for something a little bit more
mindful a bit more meaningful but even
the most advanced technology has its
limitations Nick is looking for someone
to help heal his broken heart but
algorithms that were great in big cities
are pretty useless out here in Cumbria
his apps have found it matches in
Scotland and Northern Ireland this is a
really beautiful part of the world to
live in but I suppose it's a bit
challenging when it comes to dating
you're talking about population density
yeah the least densely populated county
in England six times as many shape as
people so yeah that can be a bit of a
challenge yes so do you just end up
matching with people you know
people you've been to school where that
exact scenario a childhood friend it
turned out to be his ex-wife when we
went on a date yeah that kind of put he
did put a dampener on things to be
honest yeah
the reason why I'm single is I lost my
wife coming up three years ago single
for a good while after that and then it
came a point where I thought I was may
be ready to at least meet people anyway
it's a strange kind of world to be yeah
to get involved in I remember one of the
odd things the first time I went on a
dating up about a year ago maybe
deliberating so much over pictures you
know it's like a left swipe right swipe
kind of system and then after a few
weeks of that it's yeah you spend less
time over it I think it can be it could
be quite depressing that hall saying yes
it's not sensitive I was if the usual
alternatives but you know again you
living in a county such as this less
opportunities movie it's harder to
imagine a world further removed from
Nick's life in rural Cumbria London a
sprawling metropolis where millions of
invisible threads are connecting people
looking for love and lust
for kinks stuff this FetLife and there's
whittler for swing stuff there's KK
there's heaven circle there's fab
swingers
there's filled there's a new one coming
out called wild which is coming over
from France more users means more choice
more nation speciality apps like the
ones for kinky and fetish sex alice is a
swinger she does threesomes and group
sex among other things she's been on the
scene for about six years and the apps
she says have changed everything they
got into it through these kinds of
networking and dating apps I imagine
it's a lot easier now to find
like-minded people to find suitable
events your circle is a lot bigger it's
a lot more publicized there seems to be
a little bit of something for everyone
you have the completely vanilla
conservative people who would never do
anything only have monogamous
relationships you have the tourists the
people who are primarily monogamous
couples who fancy a little bit of spice
maybe they'll come try something out and
then you have the the lifestyle it's
where they develop friends on the scene
they like who they are in that in that
setting they like the person they can be
and then they very much get drawn into
it these apps have their place but most
users eventually want something less
extreme and more permanent we've lost a
piece of cake as well Julie a dentist
from Manchester was single and looking
for love but into her late 20s and
having had no luck with finding a
boyfriend she felt time was beginning to
run out then one Christmas a few years
ago she took her search for mr. right
online one year it was Christmas I was
sat with my flatmate we were both single
and we've watched Bridget Jones and I
found myself comparing myself to Bridget
Jones I thought this is me
do something about it and then I think
an advert came on and it was free
membership for three months there and
then I just signed up first thought
let's let's do this let's give it a
whirl
[Music]
you really celebrated the fact that you
two had met online through your wedding
yeah yeah we did so at our wedding our
table and the names of our tables on our
wedding were all named after different
dating apps so our top table was matcom
then we had plenty of fish we had Grindr
because everybody knew that that was how
we met and we can't yeah we definitely
wanted to celebrate it Julie and Matt
are now expecting their second baby a
new generation whose parents have
probably met on a dating app but who
knows how much dating will have changed
by the time they grow up and are ready
to look for love